[Music]
do you think
it's unkind to suppose
let the deserts home for
rose guess i
always wish i could know
things that you never told me
[Music]
sometimes it's so real i
can swear
i can see you standing right there
with the sand in your eyes
[Music]
come on
[Music]
you have to let me know where you are if
you want this freedom to be on your own
okay
sorry hello
birthday to time
father and if the son and of the holy
spirit amen
[Music]
crazy
[Music]
crazy
[Music]
i'm crazy
crazy
[Music]
as long as you want it
and then someday
you're leaving me for somebody
myself worry
i never fit in
never could win
though i tried and i tried
this feeling
i feel out of place
like a failed chair
[Music]
ah
[Music]
thank you austin i'll be here all week
oh where are your books
who's gonna start now
hi you were so
much like your tattei
did you know when you were a baby
he would get this guitar
and play trying to make you sleep
and i would sing
i miss those days what was it like
the philippines
crowded hot
lots of kids everywhere
but we had our family
your friends but you thought i wanted
more
mom this isn't the life you wanted
it doesn't matter
it'll be better for you i promise
[Music]
i'm
[Music]
[Music]
break time's over
good evening how are you good um just
one room
one room uh credit card and the driver's
license please
uh
hey rose hey elliot what brings you in
today
i just need to get some strings sure uh
could you get the ones and left
they're a little cheaper yeah
i like your notebook oh thanks towns is
like
my spirit god it's like dead flowers
so uh why don't you let me hear you play
uh probably never
i don't really perform for other people
just kind of play for fun i guess
oh you see this he's playing in austin
next week
cool i'm uh
i'm going if you if you wanted to come
with me
oh my mom wouldn't let me go aren't you
a senior next year
um i mean
it's not like a date i mean other
friends will be there too
i don't know it's summer come on
ask her
[Music]
you